The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And last time, you
got to see how you can derive
macroscopic thermodynamic
results from the microscopic
point of view of statistical
mechanics.
So in contrast to the way we'd
gone through the course from
the beginning, starting from
empirical macroscopic
observation and ideas through
macroscopic laws and then
working out the consequences
of them, in statistical
mechanics you start from a
microscopic model, build up
the energy levels that are going
to give you the terms in
the partition function,
determine the partition
function, and what you saw last
time is that given that,
you can calculate everything.
You can calculate all the
macroscopic properties that
ordinarily come from the
thermodynamic laws that were
based on empirical macroscopic
observation.
So today, I just want to
continue doing some
statistical thermodynamics.
Basically going through a few
examples, just to see how it
plays out when we calculate
thermodynamic quantities,
based on our microscopic
picture.
So let's just look
at a few cases.
And I'll start with a couple of
examples that are entirely
entropy driven.
And we've seen them
before from the
macroscopic point of view.
What we should hope, of course,
is that we can derive
those results from the partition
functions that are
appropriate here.
So, we'll look at entropically
driven processes.
And the first one, the simplest
one, maybe, to cover,
is just free expansion
of a gas.
So what happens if we've got
particles in a gas that are
enclosed in a certain volume.
And now we let the volume expand
into vacuum on the
other side.
Of course, you know
what'll happen.
The volume will be filled
and we've derived the
thermodynamics for it before.
So let's see what happens in a
statistical mechanical treatment.
So let's say, here's V1,
there's our gas.
There's vacuum.
And now we'll open it up and
just have the bigger volume,
V2, and let the gas fill it.
So I think last time you got
introduced to basically a
lattice model for translational
motion.
And I started in on this
just a little bit
the time before also.
So this is a simple way to
describe the statistical
mechanics of filling
an open volume.
Filling a space with
molecules.
And all it does is say that
we're going to divide up our
available volume into little
bits that are basically the
size of an atom or a molecule,
or whatever the particle is in
the gas phase.
And say, OK, there are maybe
10 of the 30th of
those little volumes.
The little volume elements are
going to be on the order of an
angstrom cubed if it's an atom,
a little bit bigger if
it's a molecule.
And the available volume is on
the order of meters cubed.
So that works out, an angstrom
is 10 to the minus 10 meters.
And then the cube of that
is 10 to the minus 30th.
So if you look at the total
number of little volume
elements of this sort, it's on
the order of 10 to the 30th.
So, the total volume, capital
V, let's make
that distinction clear.
And in this case, all the states
of the system have
equal energies.
So in other words, it doesn't
matter we're dividing our
volume up into imagined little
volume elements.
And for both the molecular and
the system states, the energy
is the same.
It doesn't matter whether the
molecules are here, here, here
and so forth.
They're not interacting in
this picture at all.
So it doesn't matter how
close or far they
are from each other.
They can't be in the
same volume.
So all the energies
are the same.
And what that means is, in the
partition function, which is a
sum over all these terms with
these Boltzmann factors.
That have e to the minus
energy over kT.
But energy's all the same in
every one of the terms.
So in order to determine the
partition function, to
determine Q, all we have to do
is count up the total number
of states that are available.
So, our energy, our molecular
translational energy, we'll
just set it to zero.
Same with our system
translational energy.
We'll set that to zero.
All the microscopic available
states, that is, if I take an
individual particle and I say
where it can be, all those
states have the same energy.
If I take a microstate of the
system, you know, the whole
collection of the particles, all
of those states also have
the same energy.
So what that means is that
little q is just equal to
capital V over little
v, right?
How many states are there?
Well, I've got my little volume,
and then however many
individual cells there are,
that's the number of available
states in this model.
So it's big V over little
v, on the order
of 10 to the 30th.
And then, big Q, the canonical
partition function for the
whole system, it's something
that we've
been through before.
It's this process of saying,
well, you take the first atom
or molecule, and it has any one
of these possible states.
So it's on the order of 10 to
the 30th possibilities.
Then where does the
second one go?
Well, there are basically
10 to the 30th more
possibilities.
And the third one has
10 to the 30th.
Since there are so many fewer
atoms or molecules then there
are volume elements, when we're
dealing with the gas
phase, we don't have to worry
about the fact that, well the
first million of the atoms
filled some of the sites.
So the next ones have fewer
sites available to them.
It's true, but it's such a small
fraction that are ever
filled that we don't need
to worry about it.
So Q is just little q to
the capital N power,
the number of particles.
And then we've seen you have
to divide by N factorial to
avoid the overcounting of
configurations that are in
fact not distinguishable.
The whole idea that maybe
there's an atom here and
another one here.
That configuration is
indistinguishable from the
configuration with those two
atoms reversed if we're
dealing with a mole of
identical atoms.
So, OK.
There's our capital Q. And
that's also our system
degeneracy.
So the degeneracy, the little
g for the molecular
degeneracy, how many molecular
states are there
of a certain energy.
Well, it's the same
thing as q.
And it's the same thing here
for the system states.
The capital Omega is
just equal to that.
Well, now let's look at what
happens when we do this.
When we expand from volume
V1 to volume V2.
So that capital V is
going to change.
So capital V1 goes
to capital V2.
And we know it's entropically
driven.
Let's calculate the
change in entropy.
So delta S is just k log capital
Omega 2 minus k log
capital Omega 1.
Now, in the process of just
seeing how the development
goes, how you can derive all
these thermodynamic quantities
from the partition function, one
of the really most central
results concerns the entropy.
How you can describe the
entropy in terms of the
probabilities that the different
states are occupied.
And how, in the case like this,
where the states all
have the same probability of
being occupied, then you have
this very simplified form
for the entropy.
Just, if S is k log capital
Omega, where capital Omega is
the degeneracy.
The number of system states
of that energy.
An amazing result.
You told them about Boltzmann's
tombstone and so forth.
So it's on there.
In fact, the ill acceptance of
that result kind of led to the
tombstone being erected
when it did.
Boltzmann, depressed over the
lack of acceptance of his
theories, put himself
to an early death.
And this was off a big
part of the reason.
But we, generations later,
have come to accept the
results that concerned
him so deeply.
So this is our change in
entropy, when we just have
this expansion of gas
from V1 to V2.
So it's just k log
omega 2, omega 1.
So now let's just put in our
results for the volumes.
It's k log V2 over v, I'm
exaggerating the size there.
To the N, over N factorial,
over V1 over v to the N
divided by N factorial.
So this is going to turn out
to be a relatively simple
case, because the factorials
are going to cancel.
So, then we just have
N k, log V2 over V1.
Terrific, right?
Now, remember, k, the Boltzmann
constant, is just
the ideal gas constant per
molecule rather than per mole.
So this is the same thing as
little N, the number of moles,
times R, times log V2 over V1.
And that should be a
familiar result.
That's the change in entropy in
expansion, free expansion
of a gas, from V1 to V2.
So now we've been able to derive
that just based on this
really simple molecular
picture.
Based on that plus the result
that Boltzmann fought and paid
so dearly for, so that
we would have it
and understand it.
As before, of course note
it's greater than zero.
If the volume, if we're
expanding into a bigger volume
than before.
The entropy goes up.
Also notice one of the other
results that you've seen is
that you could relate
the partition
function to A, right?
The Helmholtz free energy is
minus k T log Q. And S is
negative dA/dT.
And so this would immediately
give us the same result,
because omega's going
to go in here.
So we could get this result from
another pathway, too, but
a more simple and direct way is
just to start directly from
the Boltzmann result
for entropy.
Any questions?
Alright, let's go one
step more complex.
Let's now look at the
entropy of mixing.
So now we've got two species.
Rather than one expanding into a
free volume, and we're going
to open a barrier between
them and see them mix.
And again, it's still
entropically driven.
And we should be able to
calculate the entropy change
that we saw before from a
macroscopic perspective.
So, let's take a look.
So now, we have NA molecules
of A in some volume VA.
And NB molecules of B,
in some volume VB.
And then we're going
to open it up.
Then we've got capital
N, NA plus NB.
And capital V. VA
plus VB, right?
And the whole thing is
happening at constant pressure.
Well, then let's look at the
initial and final expressions
for the entropy.
So, S1, at the beginning.
It's just k log omega A plus k
log omega B. And that's k log
VA over little v to
the NA power.
Divided by NA factorial times
the same thing for B. VB over
little v to the NB power
over NB factorial.
So that's our initial entropy.
The sum of the two entropy
contributions,
from the two sides.
And S2, the final one,
is just k log omega
for the whole shebang.
And that's k log.
And now we have capital V over
little v to the N power.
And now we have a combinatorics
result that I
think probably you're all
familiar with from one context
or another.
That is, now we have
to divide by NA
factorial times NB factorial.
In other words, the amount that
we need to divide by to
avoid overcounting is the
product of those two
factorials.
Just in case it's been a while
since you've seen stuff like
that, I've got a couple of pages
further on the notes at
the bottom of the page.
I've just broken that out for a
really simple example where
there are just two molecules of
A, and two molecules of B
represented by different little
balls in lattice sites.
And I just worked it out for the
total where there are only
ten total in the mixture.
The point is, now what happens
is, when you start filling a
lattice, but it's not
all the same, right?
So now you have A here.
And A here.
And B here.
So, of course if you interchange
A and B here, you
don't have an identical state.
An indistinguishable state.
That's distinguishable and
needs to be counted.
It's only interchanging B with
B that you need to correct
for, and interchanging A with
A. So of course you need to
account for that in a way that's
different from how it
turns out if every one of the
molecules is identical.
So it's the product of
these factorials.
In the numerator.
So now delta S is then
just this minus this.
So it's k log V over little v
to the NA plus NB over VA
divided by little v to the NA
power VB divided by little v
to the NB power.
And, let's see, maybe
I'd better back up.
Let me know, that's all.
And what's happening is,
again, luckily, these
factorials are canceling.
So we just have k log V to the
NA, V to the NB over VA to the
NA VB to the NB.
And now we're going to go back
and use the fact that the
pressures are the same,
all the way through.
And what that means is that
the volumes must be in the
same ratio as the number
of molecules.
And what that means is that, for
example, VA over V is the
same as NA over N. And that's
just equal to XA, the mole
fraction of A. And the
same for B. So we
can substitute that.
And know our delta S just
becomes k log, let's see, let
me break this out from
the beginning.
And just take minus k log on XA
to the NA power minus k log
XB to the NB power.
All I've done make these
substitutions here.
For the ratios of the volume.
So it's just minus N k XA
log XA plus XB log XB.
Look familiar?
Same thing we saw
macroscopically before.
So, again, we can still use
our microscopic model.
And continue to derive the
macroscopic entropy changes.
And, of course, for many of
these we can still get our
delta G and so forth.
Of course, it's only entropy
that's going to contribute.
OK, let's look at just one more
entropy driven problem.
And that is, it's a little
bit different from these.
Let's look at the entropy
mixing in a liquid.
And the difference between the
gas and the liquid is that in
the case of the liquid, every
single cell is filled.
It's not like with the gas.
And that makes a difference
in how the
states need to be counted.
Because here, remember how
I said when we were
filling this lattice.
Well, the first molecules
goes somewhere.
And there are 10 to the
30th possibilities.
And the second molecule goes
somewhere and there are 10 to
the 30th possibilities.
And there are always 10 to the
30th possibilities because
there's so few molecules that
you never have to worry about
the fact that it's getting
filled up, so there would
become fewer possibilities
for that last molecule.
And the reason again is because
there are so few
molecules that essentially,
all the cells are open and
available even to the
last molecule.
Because maybe there's
a mole of molecules.
Maybe there are 10 to
the 24 molecules.
And there are 10 to the
30th lattice sites.
So there might be one in
a million lattice sites
occupied, even at the very
end of the procedure.
But of course for the
liquid, that's
definitely not the case.
All the available volume
is filled.
So by the time you get to that
last molecule, it has one and
only one space it can go into.
So you have to count for the
diminishment of the available
sites as molecules are
placed in them.
OK.
So it's a different kind
of combinatorics
problem that results.
So, OK.
Let's look at liquid mixture.
So now, it's going
to look like, and
they're all filled up.
I sure used fewer sites maybe,
but that'll be easier here.
We've got open circles.
So these two are going to mix.
And now we're going to
have filled mixture.
So we're going to have a bigger
volume, but it's still
going to be filled and all
the positions are random.
So we have to consider
all the possible
configurations that we have.
OK.
So we still should
go through the
same part of the procedure.
So let's call this A. And this,
B. So at first, already
the situation is different.
If we say what's the entropy
of system A. Well, in this
simple model the entropy of
the pure liquid is zero.
Now, of course, that's
not realistic.
But it's going to turn
out to be suitable.
Because the change in
entropy that we go
from here to the mixture.
The other contributions to
entropy are going to more or
less be the same from
beginning to end.
What's going to be significantly
different is
simply the fact that in the
mixture you have the random
positions that can
be occupied.
So that's going to be the term
that matters, the contribution
that matters.
So entropy is just k log
Omega A. There's
only one system state.
All of the lattice sites are
filled, and they're all filled
with A. So there's only
one way to do it.
And of course, it doesn't
matter if
you interchange them.
They're indistinguishable.
So this is zero.
This is one.
There's only one state.
Same, of course, for B.
So that's our initial entropy
in this simple model.
Well then, delta S
of the mixture is
just S of the mixture.
We don't need to worry about
the original parts.
Now, this is going to be k log
of N factorial over NA
factorial NB factorial, like
we've seen before.
That's not different
from before.
Except that unlike before, we
don't have the convenient and
simple cancellation
of the factorials.
That happened before, because
they were there.
In other words, they were
there in the entropy
contribution in the gas phase
as well, in the pure gas.
They're only there here
in the liquid.
And that means we have
to deal with them.
But it turns out it's not too
bad to deal with them.
And we're going to use this
Stirling's approximation that
I introduced before.
So the log of N factorial is
approximately equal to N log N
minus N. So let's just break
that out then, and use the
Stirling's approximation for
each of the factorial terms.
So then we have S for
the mixture is N k
log N minus N k minus.
And now we'll do the bottom,
the numerator.
NA k log NA minus NA times
k, that's this part.
And now we'll do this one.
So it's plus NB k log
NB minus NB times k.
But NA and NB, of course, are
just N. So these will cancel.
So then we're left with
NA plus NB times k
log N minus NA --
And I just want to write this
this way so that I can then
separate the terms.
Minus NA k log NA minus
NB k log NB.
And now I just want to combine
the easily combined terms.
So it's NA k log N over NA
plus NB k log N over NB.
Looks like we're home.
Now we just have N k XA log
XA plus XB log XB right?
This NA over N is just XA.
NB over is XB.
And then I've divided the same
thing to make XA's over here.
And take the total number
of moles out.
Alright.
Look familiar?
Again, the same thing derived
now in a way that's a bit
different from what we
did in the gas phase.
So now I've got the entropy of
mixing even in a condensed
phase the liquid.
And again, the reason this
simple model works is because
although a real liquid,
certainly a pure liquid has a
finite entropy, a substantial
amount of disorder, that's
present, that kind
of disorder.
In other words, the fact that
you don't really have the
molecules sitting in sites on a
lattice but there's disorder.
There's also rotational disorder
if it's a molecule.
There are various contributions
to entropy.
But those are all comparable
in the
starting and final states.
The thing that's changed is
simply the interchanging of A
and B molecules.
That's introduced a new kind of
disorder that didn't used
to be present.
A very big difference in the
number of states at the end
from the beginning.
And that's what we've calculated
and captured here.
And that's why such a simple
model still works OK.
Any questions about these
entropy driven cases?
OK.
Now let's move on and talk about
the cases which are more
commonly encountered, where
the states aren't
all the same energy.
Of course, here in the liquid,
just like in the gas, we
haven't treated interactions
between the molecules.
We've assumed that they're equal
between A and B, as they
are between A and A and B and
B. So in this case then all
the energy to the states are
the same and it's just a
counting problem.
How many states are
there available.
As soon as the energies are
different, then of course we
need to account for all those
Boltzmann factors.
Those e to the minus energy over
kT factors become part of
the, they weight the counting.
And we have to do that.
So, what I want to do is go back
to this simple polymer
configurational model that
we introduced before.
And this sort of model, in one
form or another, we're going
to see a few times in the
rest of this treatment.
The reason, really, is because
it's a simple and also
realistic way of portraying
a system that has a finite
number of well-defined
energies.
If you don't have that,
of course you
could do the treatment.
In a, sort of, classical
mechanic sense, a continuum of
states, all with different
energies.
It's hard.
Because then those sum in the
partition function become
integrals over all the different
configurations and
possibilities.
It's much more complicated
to do.
It's much more straightforward
if you can identify discrete
states and add over them.
Now, someday you'll take
quantum mechanics.
And then you'll see that the
states are discrete, even if
we're talking about
translation or
rotation and so forth.
So you'll have discrete quantum
mechanical energy
levels and so forth.
You haven't had that yet.
And so that's not the starting
point that we're going to use.
Instead, we're going to use
a starting point that goes
through the exact same
formalism, which is just the
discrete states available in
molecules that have multiple
configurations.
So we're going to have unequal
energy states.
And what we're envisioning
is molecular or polymer
configurations.
So here we have our states.
And just like before, the idea
is that if you have two
sub-units that are in proximity,
there's some kind
of favorable interaction.
It could be hydrogen bonding.
Could be different.
But the point is, there's some
sort of interaction there that
reduces the energy.
And then there are other
configurations that
just don't have that.
Because the sub-units aren't
in proximity to each other.
And it's not hard to work out
that in this very simple
model, these are the only
configurations that are available.
The only distinct
configurations.
So then, our molecular energy,
E, we can define as zero here.
Before we defined it as minus E
int, but I'm going to, it's
a little more convenient to make
this the zero of energy,
and then this is plus
the interaction for
each of these states.
Of course, we can put the zero
of energy wherever we prefer.
And then we have the
degeneracy is one.
And in this case it's three.
So now we can just write out the
configurational partition
function for the molecules and
also the canonical partition
function for the system.
So q configurational.
And we're just going to
sum over the states.
So it's e to the zero over
kT, for the lowest state.
And then there are three states
that are going to have
this term, e to the minus E
interaction over kT, where E
int is a positive number.
In other words, the probability
of any one of
these states is a little bit
lower than this state.
Because this state
has lower energy.
Remember what I mentioned
earlier, which is although the
probability of any one of these
states is lower than the
probability of this state, the
probability of this energy is
likely to be higher than the
probability of this energy.
Because there's only one
of these states and the
degeneracy here is three.
So there are three possibilities
in which the
molecule could have this energy,
and only one this.
So if, basically, kT is bigger
than E int, so in other words,
if this term isn't very much
smaller than one, then of
course this will be
bigger than this.
So of course this is one
plus three e to the
minus E int over kT.
And now we have our capital Q,
our canonical configurational
partition function.
And that's just little q
configurational to the Nth power.
And like you've seen so far,
in various cases where the
molecules are separate
non-interacting molecules,
this is just the molecular
partition function taken
capital N times.
If all the molecules are
behaving independently, then
you sum over all of
those states.
And you see that each
one of these is just
taken again and again.
As we've seen implicitly
in all these
treatments so far as well.
Now, in the translational
case where
you interchange particles.
Like particles, you have to
divide by N factorial. .
But the different configurations
don't do that.
If I've got a system where a
molecule over here is in this
configuration and a molecule
somewhere else is in this one,
and now they change
configurations, that's a
distinguishable state.
So there's no N factorial
involved here.
In the configurational
partition function.
So, fine, then it's just one
plus three e to the minus E
int over kT to the Nth power.
That's Q. And once we know Q,
as you've seen, we know
everything.
And so we can immediately start
in deriving all of the
thermodynamics, right?
And the place to start is A,
Helmholtz free energy, or
configurational free energy.
Because that's the simplest
relation, just as minus kT log
of capital Q configurational.
So it's minus N kT one
plus three e to the
minus E int over kT.
I'm going to rewrite A
configurational in terms of
beta rather than kT, just
because there are going to be
a lot of these factors.
So it's minus N kT one plus
three e to the minus beta E
interaction.
And that's our A. Everything's
going to follow from that.
Before I write some of the other
results, one thing to
notice is, it has N in it.
In other words, there's a free
energy per molecule.
The total free energy is just
something times N. And that's
because all the molecules
in this model are
independently behaving.
So whatever their average free
energy is, that's going to add
up and give us the total.
They're all acting
independently.
And in fact, we could have
gotten this directly from
minus kT log little
q configurational.
And if we look at energy,
regular energy, u,
configurational, it's minus
d log capital Q
with respect to beta.
V and N. And I'll just
write the result.
It's N times three E int e to
the minus beta E int over one
plus three e to the
minus beta E int.
And once again, the feature I
want to point out is that
there's a factor of N here.
Again, there's an energy
per molecule.
And so if we want, we can also
just write the average E,
little E, configurational.
It's just u configurational over
N. It's the same as this
without the factor of N. Not
only that, again, we could get
this directly from
the molecular
partition function up there.
From little q configurational.
We'd have the same result.
Exactly as it should be.
So if we wrote E as we've seen
in the past, it's just the sum
over that energy times the
probability for each state.
And that's just the sum of
Ei, e to the minus beta
Ei over little q.
And if you put in the terms,
you immediately get this.
Here's our little q, and this
has the interaction energy
brought out, multiplied here.
So the point is, in a case like
this, where you have a
bunch of independently behaving
particles, the totals
for these, for quantities like
energy, are simply for the
system energy, it's just the
average particle energy times
the number of particles.
The number of molecules.
And remember, before, I spoke
a little bit about the fact
that, well, if you look at one
individual molecule and
another and another, the
energy will fluctuate.
It'll vary considerably.
Of course, this is a simple
case with only
two possible energies.
But in a case where there may
be many more possible
energies, the molecular
energies
may vary quite widely.
Still, there will be a
well-defined average.
And then the system energy
would simply be the total
number of molecules
times that.
Where they're all independent.
Where all the energies are
independent of each other.
And, of course, the system
energy fluctuates a great deal
less than the individual
molecule energies.
OK, so that's our energy term.
And I think I won't write
out the results.
They're in your notes
for entropy.
For chemical potential.
They're all there.
And again, the same
point would hold.
They all scale with N. But I
want to talk a little bit
about the heat capacity.
The expression for it
isn't so simple.
So let me just right
Cv configurational.
It's du configurational / dT,
at constant V and N. And
again, the details are worked
out in the notes.
So I won't write out the
whole derivation of it.
And even writing out the
results, I'm almost
reluctant to do it.
But I'll put it up.
Three E int over k T squared,
because there are some things
I want to point out about it.
N, and then one plus three e to
the minus beta E int minus
E int e to the minus
beta E int.
Minus e to the minus beta, I
have to get rid of this.
Minus e to the minus beta E int
times negative three E int
e to the minus beta E int.
All over one plus three e to
the minus beta E int, that
whole thing squared.
And this is just, of course, the
kind of messy results that
comes from taking this
derivative with respect to
temperature and doing the chain
rule to get it with
respect to beta and so forth.
So it looks like a little bit of
an intractable, or at least
a little bit of a complicated,
function.
And the detailed functional
form is complicated.
But what I want to emphasize is
that it has simple limits
that are very easy to understand
physically.
And that are important to
understand for lots of systems.
So I just want to look at the
limits of the heat capacity at
low and high temperature.
And this is something that
recurs in statistical
mechanics, in an enormous number
of systems where you
have simplified limits.
And they're really important.
Because what's going
to matter is this.
Maybe I shouldn't have covered
up those configurations.
So there's a big difference in
what happens when kT is much
bigger than this energy.
Where you know that under those
conditions - let's say
it's hot, and this is a small
energy difference.
Then the probabilities are
essentially equal.
That the molecules are
in this state or in
any of these states.
Because the energy is
so tiny compared
to the thermal energy.
The molecules are continually
being kicked around between
all the states, among
all those states.
So the high temperature limit,
physically, is one that's
simple to understand.
Where now you're really just
going to revert to the cases
that we've treated before, where
all the energies are
effectively the same.
Because compared to
kT, they are.
And in the low temperature
limit, now go to
the opposite limit.
Let's say kT is much,
much, smaller than
the interaction energy.
So that now this term
is really small.
Because this is much
bigger than this.
So, what it means physically
is all the molecules are in
the ground state.
The probability of this
is basically one.
The probability of being in any
of these states is zero.
And that's also a
simple result.
And there are lots and lots of
cases where one of those
limits really obtains.
If you look at molecules moving
around in the gas phase
or in a liquid.
And you say, well, OK,
let's think about
their rotational motion.
Rotational energies are small.
At room temperature, kT's
much bigger than them.
You immediately go to the
high temperature limit.
Now let's go to a small molecule
and look at the
vibrational energy.
In most cases, the vibrational
frequency is pretty, molecules
are pretty stiff.
And in many cases you can just
say, look, forget it.
All the molecules are
in the ground state.
And again, in the opposite,
but also simple
limit ends up holding.
Or molecular electronic
states, right?
If you've got benzene or
hydrogen atoms in, say, at
room temperature, how many
hydrogen atoms thermally are
going to be up in the n equals
two state, the 2p
state or the 2s state?
Forget it.
There's not nearly enough
thermal energy to do that.
So these simpler limiting cases
play a huge role in
simplifying statistical
mechanics and the calculations
from them generally.
OK, so let's just see
what happens.
So, this we want, so this
we can move down.
So our limiting cases, when T
goes to zero, not going to
work out what happens to
all the betas, beta
gets big in that case.
But the result is that Cv
configurational goes to zero.
That's the limit where, like
I've described, here is E
interaction, or E int.
Here is zero.
And your kT is barely
above zero.
So when all the molecules are
here, none of them has enough
thermal energy to be up here.
So why should the heat
capacity be zero?
The heat capacity is du/dT.
It's zero because, here's kT.
Let's say I increment
kT up a little bit.
I just heat the system
a tiny, tiny bit.
An infinitesimal amount, to
look at the derivative.
Once I do this, how many
molecules are in this
higher level now?
Still zero, right?
There's still not nearly enough
thermal energy to have
any molecules up here.
So what, was the derivative of
the energy with respect to the
temperature?
I changed the temperature.
The energy didn't
change a bit.
And that means the heat
capacity is zero.
Now let's look at
the other limit.
High temperature limit.
Really, it doesn't need
to be infinity.
It's really just T greater than,
much bigger than, kT is
much bigger than
E interaction.
And in this case, kT
is much less than
the interaction energy.
So it doesn't need to be
nearly that extreme.
Well, what you find out is the
heat capacity is zero.
Now, it's zero.
Because we're in the
following limit.
Now kT is way up here.
Compared to kT, E interaction
is way down here.
So, what happens?
It means that this is so hot,
that term, The e to the minus
E int over kT, forget
it, it's one.
And so the probability, in
other words, that the
molecules are in this
state or this state
are essentially equal.
So now let's say I raise
the temperature
a little bit higher.
What happens to those
probabilities?
What changes?
Right.
Nothing changes.
So what happened to the energy
when I raised the temperature?
Of course, nothing
happened to it.
Which means the heat
capacity is zero.
Now, the first limit that
I described, this
one is almost universal.
For any system where you have
quantized level, you can
always eventually get to a low
enough temperature that you're
in the first limit.
Where the kT is lower than,
by far, than the
first excited level.
Everything's in the
ground state.
And so you reach this limit.
This one, it's only cases
where you have a
finite number of levels.
Then you have the same high
temperature limit to it.
In other words, the reason this
result happens is because
there aren't a bunch of other
levels up here that eventually
get to be comparable to kT.
And not all kinds of systems
or degrees of
freedom are like that.
This one is, because there's a
finite number, four in this
case, of configurations.
So there's just nothing
above there.
There's another really important
kind of degree of
freedom like that.
And that's spin.
Think of proton spins.
It's plus 1/2 or it's minus
1/2, and that's it.
You can't put any more
spin energy into it.
Just like you can't put any more
configurational energy
into the system than to
be in this state.
That's it.
So in other words, the maximum
possible energy is finite.
Of course, lots of other
degrees of freedom are
different from that.
If you think a molecule's
rotating, they could always
spin faster.
Vibrating, they can
always vibrate
harder, translate faster.
Those degrees of freedom
won't have this limit.
They also will have a simple
high temperature limit, but
not zero, because, of course,
if there are always more
levels, and I keep increasing
kT, then I'll have thermal
energy to go into those higher
and higher levels.
It'll still go up.
But for systems with a finite
number of possible levels, and
a finite amount of total energy,
for degrees of freedom
like that, once I get to a
temperature higher than any of
that stuff, then forget it.
You can't change the energy
anymore thermally.
So your heat capacity is zero.
You can change the temperature
and nothing further happens.
OK, next time we'll see what
happens when you do have
continuing basically unbounded
possible energies.